I had estrogen receptive receptor progesterone receptor positive breast cancer. I am seeing a doctor
for emotional trauma and anxiety. She noticed in her scans on her third mug roughly that
a pituitary is not functioning properly. She recommends these supplements, standard process pituitary
PMG, hypothelmous PMG, and hypothelmix. So three are taken at three times at breakfast, three times
at dinner, possibly for three weeks. Nervous because of hormone receptive positive breast cancer
and what are it if that may affect like hormones that are conflict with the large supplement
or regimen that I am currently on. Pituitrophin is derived from bovine,
gerutary extract. That sounds a little scary. I lived in germany during the bad cow outbreak.
What are your thoughts on these supplements? I'll take them together. Would it be safer or more
effective to just run the pituitary normalizing programs on the right? So I know you are taking
a lot of supplements, so I know you are concerned about adding more to your regimen.
So you have to weigh that out as well. So what are the standard process pituitary PMG and hypothelmous
PMG and hypothelmix? They are what PMG stands for throttle morphogen. So throttle morphogen was
is the organ glandular nutrition. So this is glandular nutrition. So it's organ nutrition and yes,
it is going to be derived from bovine tissue. Meaning it's going to be derived from cows. So this is
cow pituitary cow hypothelmous tissue. And that's what you are consuming.
Is there a danger with this? People say, oh no, I gosh, this couldn't lead to bad cow disease.
Is there a danger to this? No, there is no danger to that for that at all. It would not be
concerned with that at all. They take it to clean organic animals, all the companies that we've
ever used. We don't sell standard process because of other reasons, but this is a good product.
You don't have to have any issues taking that. Is there a danger in taking to a Terry or hypothelmous
nutrition if you have ER, PR positive cancer? No, there's no danger in that whatsoever. Either
that's not going to increase your estrogen production. So I would not worry about that. It's just
building blocks for your pituitary. So I don't think there's any harm in taking that.
So would it be easier just to run the would it be safer to run the pituitary? I wouldn't
think it's safer. The would it be cheaper for you? Yes, would it be less supplements? Yes,
could you do both? Yes. So that's a decision you'll have to make. But there isn't any harm in taking